when any flaw shows up the glamour is
dispelled and suddenly they become
terrible hi I'm Ted bellacor with reason
TV and today I'll be sitting down with
Virginia postural Buster L is the author
of two books the future and its enemies
and the substance of style she's former
editor-in-chief of Reason magazine and
current editor-in-chief of deep glamour
net tell our viewers about deep glamour
net a deep glamour dotnet is a group
blog that I edit I write for it but I
also have a number of contributors and
it is about exploring glamour and its
many manifestations and it's deep we
write essays it's not a street fashion
blog or something like that my view of
glamour is that it is not a style it is
not just about movie stars and it is in
fact a powerful form of visual rhetoric
and persuasion and an imaginative
process like humor that takes place
between an audience and an object but
takes many different forms depending on
the audience and what they find
glamorous just like humor and depending
on the cultural context and you've
called glamour a beautiful illusion yes
a lot of people would say well maybe
that describes President Obama you know
I have to say he's like God's gift to my
glamour project because glamour is an
illusion and it is a particular form of
illusion it's an illusion that tells the
truth about the audience's desires and
it requires mystery and distance and
what you saw during the campaign was
people projecting onto Barack Obama
whatever it is that they wanted in a
president or they wanted even in a
country add to the degree that people
would project onto him the idea that he
was lying which is usually a bad thing
but they will project onto him that he
was lying about his positions because he
really secretly agreed with them as
opposed to after for example on
trade but there were other examples but
the the biggest one was about he's
really you know anybody that smart has
got to really be a free trader at heart
he's just saying this to pander to those
idiots you know he can't really mean it
and and you've seen as he's actually
taking office and tried to govern this
back and forth where he is consciously
or unconsciously trying to maintain his
glamour which requires a kind of
distance from the political process so
that people can continue to see him as
representing them regardless of their
contradictory views while actually
trying to be President which means you
have to decide what to do about
Guantanamo you have to decide you know
what health care bill you're going to
back you have to decide all these things
and you're going to make somebody
realize that their dissolution and write
this morning I saw that the former
editor of Harper's is about to write a
book the mendacity of hope attacking
obama from the left and this is I think
that's the power and the downside of
glamour let's step into the wayback
machine for a moment I'm going to read
you something you wrote in april two
thousand eight column quote obama's
glamour gives him a powerful political
advantage but it also poses special
problems for the candidate and if he
succeeds for the country can you explain
what you meant back then and how it's
played out oh one thing as a candidate
the sort of flip and also as as
president the sort of flip side of
glamour is horror people say oh there's
something hiding it must be something
terrible and so in the campaign it was
oh it must be that he's you know
secretly a radical muslim or you know
he's later on is like he's secretly
really born in kenya you know he's not
really as opposed to just you know he
has policies that are bad for the
country or something more conventional
politics objection to a candidate so
that is one type of disadvantage and the
other is the one that I just
talk about which is that there's always
this this capacity for disillusionment
even among supporters because people
have projected so much of what they
think including things that are sort of
impossible into a glamorous figure that
when any flaw shows up the glamour is
dispelled and suddenly they become
terrible is it impossible to live up to
this illusion and so is glamorous
something that's good for a candidate
but bad for a president seeking
re-election after people have realized
oh he couldn't possibly look at all the
two glamorous presidents in my lifetime
besides Obama the first was JFK and he
dealt with this problem by getting
killed and yeah I was something I didn't
want to mention in an article by Obama
but that that really I mean there were
lots of problems in the Kennedy
administration that and lots of Secrets
that were being hidden that came out
later but because he'd gotten
assassinated there was the glamour state
the other glamorous present in my
lifetime I would argue was actually
Ronald Reagan he managed to govern
because he actually did stand for some
some specific ideas that brought a broad
consensus of supporters together he was
still a figure of distance and mystery
but there was a core of identifiable
beliefs that were not an illusion that
were in fact there and that was that
enabled him to govern oh and also to
maintain this sort of glamour Oh
particularly to the Reagan coalition you
see that where people of different
persuasions you know libertarians would
say he's really more libertarian and
social conservatives would say oh he's
really more social conservative but he
did have these kinds of specific beliefs
that held those people together they
didn't hold together so well after him
how about the junior senator from
Massachusetts is Scott Brown glamorous
he's probably glamorous to some people
but I think in his case he's more
representative of a cause and it's not
about his personal glamour or what
people project into him but more you
know he's going to be that forty first
vote that that sort of thing is Sarah
Palin glamorous that's a really
interesting question um I think when she
was first nominated i wrote a post on
deep glamour about going to the cowgirl
museum in Fort Worth when i lived in
dallas i'm being surprised at what
cowgirls really like and how they were
these incredibly glamorous figures and
not entirely in an illusory way and I
think she does have some of this kind of
frontiers woman multi competent sort of
glamour to her but I think she's not
primarily a glamorous figure she's too
familiar and in fact her for people who
like her it's her familiarity her
ordinariness she's an extraordinary
version of an ordinary person ah and
that's what's appealing and that's not
glamorous so it's a different kind of
appeal it's like I don't know the appeal
of Sandra Bullock versus the appeal of
Angelina Jolie or Grace Kelly or
something she's more of the girl next
door if you